first of all we want to express our
sincere condolences
to the victim's family
a person lost their life yesterday
morning
and we think it's important to keep
focus on that as we talk about this
tragic event
we're deeply saddened
for everyone affected especially
the victim's family
that being said
we love henry ruggs
i want him to know
that his terrible lapse in judgment
of the most horrific kind
it's something that he'll have to live
with the rest of his life
the gravity of the situation is not lost
on anyone here
and we understand and respect
the loss of life
and um
with that i'll i'll try to take your
questions rich um if there's any way
that you can kind of put into words the
emotions of these last couple of days
getting a call that you probably never
want to get and then also the decision
to move on from henry as quickly as the
organization did
to be perfectly frank i don't really
know if i can put into words the
emotional um
feelings that
you know certainly i went through and
certainly uh i can't speak for our
players or our coaches or
um
our owner our organization i just know
for me as a
as a parent and a person that
cares about young people and deals with
young people every day i really don't
know if i could quantify
what the emotions are
so that being said i think
late last night or late yesterday
afternoon
as time went on and the organization
gained more
information i think you read our our
first statement
but i think as they we all gain more
information certainly
as mark gained more information i think
our
our team official team
met upstairs and and um i think we came
to the conclusion and owner mark i
thought it best for the organization um
to to do that at that particular time so
um i think there's two separate entities
there's
henry ruggs the football player which is
no longer a part of the raiders and then
henry rugg's the person who is certainly
going through um what he's going through
and is going to have to pay the
consequences for the actions
this year the locker room between uh
driver's license and can you just be a
little bit louder between uh
john green's resignation and in this
situation the locker room has been
through a lot uh i know it's only been a
day but have you seen the group sort of
pull back together kind of these
challenging moments and attempt to move
well i think
they're two totally separate you know
entities and and um
so uh i felt like we
we moved on from
what happened before and and we've had a
chance to play two games and and now
we've we've been confronted um with this
situation and again as grown men we all
have to respond
in a certain way we're all forging our
identity um in life and uh certainly in
the locker room through how uh we face
adversity and how we deal with adversity
that's kind of how
how life goes so i think they understand
that we've had conversations about that
and
for us as
coaches and players it's always good to
get on the grass
and grind through a wednesday's practice
and full pads and
um
now i'm here answering questions
you've made a life and a living out of
game planning preparing for lots of
variables
this is as unpredictable as adversity
gets
how helpless is that as a leader
you know
there's no blueprint for this there's no
there's no handbook
that they give you for the obstacles
that you occur
um whether you're a parent whether
you're a teacher whether you're
you know my dad drove a truck so there's
no blueprint for these things and um i
just think we all lean on each other in
there there's a lot of other coaches
that we have on staff that have a lot of
experiences we have players that have
gone through other things so i think
we've done a good job of communicating
with each other um
and uh you know we've we've tried to
give the best resources that we have to
our players within montel and miss jean
and people at um in their department and
then certainly what we've done
um as coaches so um again
we'll see how we respond to to the
situation we're in
the back end of that uh even despite the
tragic incident uh how much of this can
you turn this around also like for you
as a coach but also the leaders in the
locker room how much will this be able
to stress accountability against amongst
each other to really just hold each
other accountable and make each other
the best players possible on and off the
field well you know
we are involved in man building around
here and we do coach the the man first
and the players second and again we
we've talked about these things
um before they've happened
um
you know at length i'm sure every team
does but um
again
put himself in a bad situation
made a choice that has certainly altered
his life and and that's really where
we're at so i think they all know that i
think they've seen that
but we've seen it before
and obviously it
it caught up to us now so
i
don't really know if i answered that but
that's kind of where i'm at rich with
all due respect to the tragedy setting
that aside and getting to football for a
second for you you get to go home to the
team that your dad loved growing up
and you just speak to the emotions of
that i mean what a journey for you to be
able to go back there to the team you're
dead
yeah against them yeah i think i made a
comment that first press deal my dad was
the head coach of the giants he just
never told anybody and i don't think
anybody got that i think they were
googling and seeing my dad was head
coach of giants so um fortunately for me
i've played against them a lot now you
know when we were in dallas we obviously
played up there every year and when i
was in town had a chance to play up
there so um for me again it's
it's always exciting to go to go um
certainly home but for us it's a it's a
huge challenge right coming off a buy
everyone's written about our record
coming off the buys haven't been very
good
um here as of late and um you know we're
going to leave on a friday
and we're going to go up there and play
a big physical well coach football team
so that's really more of the challenge
for me than than i'm actually going home
rich after releasing willie snead and
henry ruggs you guys only have i think
three receivers on the roster right now
if you consider either you know making a
practice file promotion or adding
somebody from youtube we have we've had
conversations and we have um we have
stoner and whims and and um there's this
conversation about others as well but uh
we're gonna probably stay status quo
this week and we know we have a chance
to to possibly move stoner up and then
we have wins that's not a good job and
we'll see how that turns out before the
end of today's over but it would be
those two
coach earlier today uh joe judge was
kind of speaking about the relationship
that you guys have and said some things
about you what kind of what would you
say is uh some things you admire about
coach judge yeah i mean i know a lot
about joe you know i know his trip to
mississippi state and through alabama
and the coaches he's had a chance to be
around and then special teams coaches in
the league you know we kind of have a um
you know maybe a special bond or
certainly a um a connection because we
go through the same the same obstacle so
uh the only thing i'd i'd say about joe
is um he's he's a tough guy and he comes
from detailed coaches which makes him an
extremely detailed
head football coach you can see it on
film they do a lot of things in the
kicking game they're well coached on on
defense and certainly i know a lot about
you know jason um being with him for
five years so
my relationship with joe goes back a
long time we have a lot of the same
um mentors that we we've been around
before and so again i appreciate all his
kind words and whatever he said about me
if it was good
just take him and rewrite him about him
if you could that would help me
we got a chance to talk to henry
no actually no we have not um
i don't even think anything happened
till nine o'clock this morning so we
weren't allowed to or didn't have a
chance to speak to him at all yesterday
if you could speak to him what would you
say
yeah i'll just leave that to when that
happens
when you gather the team either last
night i guess it was virtually or today
around what was what was the mood and
how much of this week is
managing them
kind of
you know coming to grips with everything
but also getting ready for a game and
how do you kind of balance that yeah
well the first time we uh we actually
got our team together um yesterday late
afternoon at four o'clock we had a zoom
with the whole team i just we thought it
was important that we get on
uh zoom so they could kind of see our
faces see my face and we tried to
deliver a message and at that particular
point what we wanted to do there was so
much misinformation out there we were
getting so many different stories
um that what we wanted to do was give
them the facts that we had at that
particular time so if you go back to
four o'clock in the afternoon um that's
what we did to give them some sense of
what's going on here's what i'm hearing
you know a lot of players were texting
and um coming by the office and those
things so we that's what we accomplished
and then
certainly what transpired last night
went into the release of henry and then
this morning's team meeting
we addressed kind of what happened last
night we addressed some of the new
information that had come out which we
thought would all come out at nine
o'clock this morning
which i think has so they got a chance
to see that and we then we just talked
about
um what are charges going forward
individually
and then collectively how we can put it
together for a grind it competitive
practice on a wednesday and what it'll
look like in the meeting after practice
and then what it's going to look like
when you go home
what does it look like when you come
back in the morning so we're just trying
to stay for the most part
you know we're trying to be where we are
and um
move through this this uh
as slowly as we possibly can and as
communicative with um some clear or
clarity as to what we're expecting of
each other as we keep moving forward
richard some of your players have talked
about when you coach them you talk about
seizing their opportunity making the
most when the opportunity comes
is is that kind of what you'll be
emphasizing to is a jones and some of
the young receivers this week you know
again those are those are great words
and cliches and those things but
zay's made a lot of plays you know in
the games that we've played in and you
know people don't even notice you know
what he's done playing flyer out there
on the punt team and he's on kickoff
return and so um you know we had this
conversation a week ago darren waller
didn't play
only people surprised that foster did
what he did i guess was the media
because certainly no one in the locker
room was surprised what foster did so we
have a high expectation for what what
zay can bring us just like it's what
he's brought us um up to this point so
we're all going to get opportunities
throughout
the course of our you know careers and
and our our time here and again it's
it's how we respond to the opportunity
given to us let's do two more guys adam
well
josh and darren josh and darren were
practicing there yep actually we're
clean today i was pretty fired up about
that so coach
about the captains uh did you
specifically meet with each of them
individually and like how has the
captains kind of taken upon themselves
to meet with the different groups that
they uh represent yeah and actually we
actually had a a unity council meeting
um on
monday before all this
happened and the captains are on that
and then there's other
basically um hand-picked players for
myself that that i met with i think
there's a total of 14 of them so we
actually had a lot of conversations
about a lot of different things on
monday after that um the expectation for
the captains they were voted on by their
teammates so our expectation for them
would be in the locker room there should
be a lot of conversation there should be
a lot of chatter amongst each other um
and we like to talk about uh
positive
self-communication in our locker room
for them
no disrespect to anyone but there's a
lot of people that like to you know to
push and um some of their questions may
push them and some of those things but i
think in our locker room we'd like them
to be um have their comments or have
their conversations be positive to some
degree if it's something they want to
discuss that
is negative they certainly have the
right um to do that that's their office
that's their their home in there and
then again we have plenty of resources
for them um if they have questions
outside of the realm of what we could
help them with or the um the captains or
the guys on the council can help them
with that we have plenty of resources to
get them helped that way